et si les châteaux sont nombreux dans le
département les parcs d'attractions tout
autant aurélie les un indice pour
découvrir un premier lieu si je vous dis
maquette miniature à bravo week end
n'avait pas de micro perdu france
miniature signatures fait bien michael
bravo le seul endroit évidemment dont
kyle en cours où vous pouvez faire le
tour de france en quelques heures on
rappelle 1 117 monuments sont reproduits
il ya également quelques manèges et pour
cet été eh bien le parc vous invite au
cirque des zinzins sous un chapiteau un
circuit avec des petites voitures et
puis à 4 mètres au dessus du sol il ne
faut pas avoir le vertige 20 ateliers
permettent de tester votre équilibre
quelques explications supplémentaires
avec le directeur de france miniature la
thématique du cirque parce que c'est
vraiment pour consensuelle en fait c'est
très familial
et ça plaît énormément aux enfants donc
les plans voulais que ça soit aussi des
jeux d'aventuré le défi et ne cire que
s'y prête par les jeux d'ateliers et
d'équipements alors le cirque des
zinzins bien sûr est compris dans le
prix du billet je le rappelle 20 euros
pour les adultes 16 euros pour les
enfants j'ai quand même un bon plan qui
va faire du bien à votre portefeuille
puisque si vous prenez vos billets en
ligne sur le site france miniature point
fr moins cher voilà alors les familles
du coup exactement parce qu'on dépense
pendant les vacances
juste un mot sur le cirque des onze ans
et est accessible aux enfants à partir
de 1 mètre et pour participer il faut
impérativement avoir des chaussures
fermées à partir d'un mètre a priori ici
tout le monde peut participer même mois
autre part qu'à proposer des nouveautés
pour cet été au parc de thoiry
oui et l'expérience proposée s'appelle
wild forest qui veut dire en anglais
forêt faune sauvage sauvage sur bravo
fort et là j'ai fouillé dans mon
association
alors cela permet tout simplement d'être
en immersion avec certains animaux alors
cela existait en déjà puisqu'on pouvait
être en immersion avec des kangourous ou
encore avec des lémuriens
mais depuis quelques semaines et ben
vous pouvez côtoyer de très mignon d'un
ou encore plus insolite des vautours sur
un million oui c'est moins mignon
alors c'est vrai que ces oiseaux en fait
on en très mauvaise presse en mais
rassurez-vous n'y a aucun danger puisque
vous êtes dans une volière de 500 mètres
carrés qui est fermée donc dans laquelle
plusieurs rapaces et volubile pouvez y
laisser vos enfants pendant que vous
visitez le pape apparemment moore qui a
priori il n'y a pas de danger alors que
grégory et déjà habillé
pour se fondre dans le décor merci
michael mais vous êtes un peu sur le
même thème également également alors
certaines espèces en fait de vautours
sont en voie d'extinction et du coup
c'est cette zone d'immersion en fait un
rôle pédagogique comme nous l'expliquent
mathieu décombe c'est le responsable
adjoint du service aventure à thoiry on
voit que à l'intérieur de ces zones
d'immersion les gens sont beaucoup plus
concentrés beaucoup plus détendue et
puis vont être plus à l'écouté pour
apprendre plein de choses sur les
animaux puisque c'est un nos principaux
rôles les moisséens c'est mon travail
ici à thoiry ça va être d'expliquer
plein de choses sur les animaux aux
visiteurs les sensibiliser à leur
protection et dans ces zones d'immersion
on arrive encore mieux le faire durant
l'été il devrait faire beau ça a plutôt
bien commencé mais si jamais quelques
gouttes de pluie s'invite
il ya une solution et les parcs de jeux
intérieure ce sont des structures qui
sont réservées généralement aux enfants
de 1 à 12 ans alors ils peuvent bien sûr
un se défouler sur des châteaux
gonflables des trampolines des toboggans
des piscines à balles
il en existe plusieurs dans les yvelines
et justement il ya seulement quelques
mois un nouvel établissement ouvert ses
portes du côté de gaz rend si juste à
côté de rambouillet
son nom les mini kids j'ai fait une
étude de marché j'ai vu que dans le
secteur y avait rien pour les enfants et
donc j'ai trouvé que c'était très
intéressant d'ouvrir un lieu dédié aux
enfants sur embrouillé c'est quand même
des structures très grande pour les
personnes qui habitent parfois en
appartement on n'a pas ce genre de
superficie et des jeux de cette taille
pour pouvoir occuper ses enfants pendant
plusieurs heures et le petit plus dans
ce parc est bien il ya un snacking donc
du coup les parents peuvent se détendre
en buvant un café en feuilletant un
magazine et puis évidemment tout en
surveillant leurs enfants infos
pratiques ces 7 euros pour les enfants
de moins de 3 ans 10 euros pour les
enfants à partir de 3 ans et c'est
gratuit pour les adultes plus d'infos
sur le site qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
merci aurelia un parc d'attractions qui
vous attire plus qu'un autre dans le
département ou parcs d'attraction ou non
je pense à thoiry aussi mais moi j'ai
testé les cinq des onze ans c'est pas
mal an cirq dans un bonne expérience
michael je suis plus touahri j'adore toi
et l'adorer touahri pour les animaux
pour les voir les animaux balaiera pas
celle que je vais essayer de me fondre
dans le décor également à et grégory
peut-être cet été
nature pour défendre et militants chacun
pourra y trouver à grégory va tout prix
partagé avec nous son expérience des
parcs pour partager avec vous parce que
j'étais un peu frustré tout à l'heure
sur la chronique de nicolas ce qui est
très important aurélie vous le savez un
veau qui présentait des émissions c'est
bien s'hydrater entre les plateaux en
plus il fait chaud
donc je vais vous offrir ce petit verdot
voilà pour vous reposer après cette
longue chronique
c'est très mignon et ça permet de
relever un nouveau défi de fil rouge
depuis le début de cette émission
restent dans la thématique des parcs de
loisirs et un parc vous n'avez pas cité
et c'est la fête des loges trois cent
soixante sept ans qu'elle se déroule
dans un forêt a de saint-germain-en-laye
c'est jusqu'au 18 août l'événement
forain est le plus ancien de france mais
il ya toujours des nouveautés reportage
c'est sa première alors qu'yves août à
tous les manèges sera pas cette année ce
sera l'année prochaine
que ce soit pour une balade en famille
ou des sensations fortes entre amis la
fête des loges à plein de ressources
pour cette 367e les visiteurs peuvent
découvrir plus de 200 animations stands
jeux
et bien sûr les traditionnels manèges je
pense que c'est merveilleux
c'était génial vraiment génial et bien
c'est quoi c'est plus convivial que la
foire du trône qui est très grande a
fait un peu plus convivial et on respire
c'est mieux si certains sont venus pour
un moment de détente d'autres ont bien
sûr profité de la visite en forêt de
saint germain en laye pour monter dans
les attractions les plus
impressionnantes et le courage n'est pas
à bloc chez tout le monde
je sais pas j'aime pas les sensations
fortes j'ai peur il laisse aller
encourager ce que nous entendons
d'ajustement des sensations fortes mais
on aime ça donc on choisit les malaises
les plus attentionnés
c'est la première et la seule à temps
que wayne on la sait ça nous a retourné
un petit peu le coeur mais vous avez
jusqu'au 18 août pour profiter de la
fête des loges plus de deux millions de
visiteurs sont attendus sur place cet
été